is this what I think it is
I'll help you get this Superman
Welcome back
everyone DC is so confident in The Flash movie
they've been showing it to everyone with a pair of
eyes to Hype it up and now apparently they've also
screened it for Henry Cavill himself so we got
him reacting to the movie I'll explain how he fits
into all this in The Flash movie and because of
James Gunn's big DC reboot Henry Cavill Superman
is still in the movie just not in the same way
that he was before the reboot if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll start giving away tickets to the movie
in this video I'll just pick random people from
the comments all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber and let me know where you want
to see Henry Cavill Superman come back if we know
he's not going to be in the Superman Legacy movie
but Henry Cavill himself said that he'd eventually
come back as a version of Superman but recently
in your feed you probably saw Sasha clay who
plays the new supergirl talking about Henry Cavill
she did a big feature recently talking about her
character in the movie and explained when they
first cast her the video of her still online
with director Andy muschietti voice chatting with
her to tell her she got the part and her reaction
just freaking out because it is a huge deal being
cast as super girl when she was talking about her
Supergirl in the movie she said that she'd met
both Henry Cavill and Melissa who played DCTV
Supergirl to get their advice on The Flash movie
and her performance as Supergirl just becoming a
version of the character in general I met him
after I finished the movie okay clear that up
um I didn't speak to him till very very after we
finished the movie and we brief ly met I gave him
a hug he is so sweet and so kind um and you know
he you know I was obviously like nerding out and I
was like did you did I make you proud did you like
my you know you know I was like did I as Superman
did I make you proud and he was like absolutely
you killed it and that meant a lot to me
um of course it did you know I I have large
respect for him and what he has done and
um yes do you know what the symbol stands
for means hope right what's the S stand for
it's not an s on my world it means hope maybe
it's not a surprise that Henry Cavill is such
a gentleman if you've ever watched any interviews
with him talking about Superman talking about the
DC movies or just any interviews in general even
if he's not talking about the DC movies like his
other stuff he is the consummate gentleman like
he doesn't actually get up to a lot of the beef
stuff that you see he's like the Rock and Vin
Diesel get up to let the rock even started going
after people on Twitter a little after the
Black Adam movie started to get bad reviews
Henry Cavill is way cooler about stuff like
that like he doesn't get up to a lot of that
kind of drama but it is cool to hear him give
his stamp of approval to the movie and to Sasha
Clay's version of Supergirl just in general a
lot of people who have seen the movie said that
she is actually one of the better parts of the
movie too so I'm actually pretty hopeful about
her I believe the way they explained the switch
in the movie like the combining timelines The
Flash uses a version of hyper time in the speed
force to basically overlap a bunch of timelines
where different things happen he tries to run back
in his own timeline of that Justice League earth
like the main timeline it winds up crossing over
into Michael Keaton Batman's timeline and then
also crosses over with Supergirl's timeline
which is from another timeline combining like
this third even different timeline with a bunch of
amalgam things all combined on this single Earth
so Supergirl isn't meant to be originally from
Michael Keaton Batman's or she's from a completely
different timeline it's just all these different
timelines being combined together because of the
Flash's mistakes that's where they get to the
flash point of it all and in the new amalgam
timeline when Zod comes to destroy Earth he's
also just destroyed Superman's pod when he was
still a baby so when the flash is taking everyone
to go look for Superman in this underground bunker
that's why they find Sasha Clay's Supergirl
because her pod wound up landing on Earth that
storyline is taken from the original Flashpoint
story that Superman got where Superman's pod was
captured by the military and they kept him in an
underground bunker to prevent him from becoming
super strong but they're not using this new weird
amalgam timeline to completely replace everything
from the Justice League timeline it's just meant
to be like this weird offshoot amalgam timeline
that the flash is on for a little while during
the movie and because he spends so much time
in the speed force like Back to the Future style
trying to go back in time or change the timeline
multiple times there are a lot of Cameo scenes
during the speed force and I don't think that
DCTV Supergirl is supposed to be referenced
during the movie I think the closest they get
to DCTV arrowverse references is supposed to be a
cameo from Teddy Sears as a version of Jay Garrick
which is pretty surprising not only is it weird
because he was more of a version of Hunter zoloma
like a completely different character pretending
to be a version of Jay Garrick on the TV show
you'd also expect that they'd have a Grant
Gustin Cameo to pay off the Ezra Miller crisis
on infinite Earth's Cameo scene during that
crossover he even hears Grant gustin's flash
use the name the flash for the first time I'm
also flash you also the what the flash flash
during the movie you hear them call him the flash
so like he's been the flash for a while it'd be
fun if they actually explained that he started
using that name because he heard it during crisis
on infinite Earth and just liked it so much but
Henry Cavill recently explained the long-term plan
for Superman just based on James Gunn's reboot
originally before the reboot DC had a plan to
bring him back and do Man of Steel too the Black
Adam post credit scene was meant to help set that
up the funny thing about that is that Brainiac was
going to be one of the big villains during Man of
Steel 2. and reportedly Brainiac is also going
to be one of the big villains in the Superman
Legacy movie going back to Richard Donner's
Superman he also wanted to use a version of
Brainiac in his movies at some point too but for
some reason wasn't able to so they've been trying
to do Brainiac for years now in Superman movies
but that's why right after the Black Adam movie
came out Henry Cavill went on his Instagram and
posted this video talking about finally coming
back for more Superman I wanted to wait until the
weekend was over before posting this uh because I
wanted to give you all the chance to watch Black
Adam but now that plenty of you have I wanted to
make it official that I am back as Superman and
the image you see on this post and what you saw in
Black Adam are just a very small taste of things
to come so uh there's a lot to be thankful for and
I'll get to that in time but I want to thank you
guys most of all thank you for your support and
thank you for your patience I promise it will be
rewarded things got weird because shortly after
that happened shortly after he posted that video
James Gunn was hired by DC he executes his reboot
plans and because he wants to do Superman Legacy
is like a Superman year 2 or year three movie kind
of like the Robert Pattinson version of Batman
very young version of the character they don't
think Henry Cavill can play young enough to be
that version of the character like he could play
younger but apparently they want him to be very
young thus the Superman recasting in Henry Cavill
kind of explaining what was going on with that he
did a bunch of posts about this like right after
he posts that original video like I am back but
oh yeah hold on for a second because there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that just happened
five seconds later there's the important part
when he says the opportunity for him to come back
is Superman in the future I think what James Gunn
and Henry Cavill both are thinking is Multiverse
just say that he's from the Multiverse because
they're using The Flash movie in a version of
Flashpoint to make some minor changes to the
DC movie universe that everything is going
to take place in going forward at least the
connected movies like this is the sum total of
all upcoming DC movies and where everything fits
in some of it will be clear elseworlds like
the Robert Pattinson Batman and some of the
other stuff but most of it will be connected and
what they'll do is they'll bring these characters
back and say that the Snyder verse is an alternate
universe where all the characters exist and some
of them just happen to look very similar to the
new versions because James Gunn did say that some
of the characters would continue like for instance
Amanda Waller is going to be played by the same
actress a lot of The Suicide Squad actors will be
the same Marco Robbie will continue to be a Harley
Quinn in his upcoming DC movies gal gadot's Wonder
Woman will be the same even though it's going to
be a while before she actually debuts because
of doing that the mascara prequel series Jason
Momoa is very confident that he's coming back like
he's absolutely sure but as a different character
probably Lobo it sounds like and it's just simpler
to explain that it all happens in a different
universe and because it'll be 2025 before we see
Superman Legacy in 2026 before we see the Batman
brave in the Bold movie long enough will have
gone by by the general casual audiences that don't
follow the comics will understand the concept
and different actors playing similar versions
of characters like we have The Flash movie with
Michael Keaton's Batman it's basically what's
going on between him and Ben Affleck's version
of Batman because of all the reboots though there
are a lot of Henry Cavill deleted scenes like
he just specifically shoot footage for special
Cameo meant to set up what their original plans
for this crisis on infinite Earth's movie they
were building to like their original 10-year plan
of movies so he was going to appear to the flash
in the movie and warn about some coming crisis
reportedly now they've changed that and now it's
different footage of him from the Justice League
movie there are slightly different footage of
Henry Cavill Superman in other Justice League
actors that appeared to him in the speed force
hopefully they'll release some of that footage
as deleted scenes so with Henry Cavill plans
on coming back as a version of Superman in the
future in some different way what movie do you
want that to be I feel like most of us are just
thinking crisis on infinite Earth in the movies
just do a version of crisis on infinite Earth at
some point and you can bring anybody you want back
from anywhere and as much as it sucks that Henry
Cavill isn't going to be in Superman Legacy he did
announce that Warhammer series that he's making it
sounds like the plan is to try and Premiere that
around the same time that Superman Legacy like
that same year that is coming out so it'll be a
couple years before we see it but there will be
a bunch of stuff that he's working on right now
I've already done a big video on the trailer that
he released for that so click here for that Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer and click here for my
Spider-Man across the spider-verse review video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!